Joe Biden is facing intense scrutiny for
behavior that he has been exhibiting in
public including on the world's largest
age for the past 40 years if I didn't
know any better I would say that maybe
this is just a cynical attack but what
do I know we will analyse Joe Biden's
hashtag me too moment then AOC hits
primetime on left-wing cable news and a
New York Times columnist dumps his
girlfriend's because she's white I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
I can't believe you're gonna make me
defend Joe Biden I know I tweeted this
out today I said I'm gonna be defending
Joe Biden on my show be sure to tune in
they said Oh Michael that's a funny
April Fool's joke said uh-oh that adds
insult to injury you're I not only have
to defend Joe Biden I have to defend him
on April Fool's Day which seems like
it's an April Fool's joke from me really
it's just an April Fool's joke from the
news cycle making me defend him because
this latest spate of attacks saying that
he's some sexual predator seems to me a
little more cynical than it does some
grand expose of a guy who's been in
politics for 40 years we will try to
play fair but first let's make a little
money honey with zip recruiter hiring
can be very hard multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy all
you have to do is go to that one place
to get it done zip recruiter comm slash
Knowles kayano wles zip recruiter sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't just
stop there they don't just throw
spaghetti at the wall with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within just the first
day right now my listeners get to try a
zip recruiter for free at the exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
Knolls KO wles
zip recruiter comm slash knowles kenda
wles zipper twitter.com slash no zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
creepy Uncle Joe the question is is Joe
Biden some long-standing sexual
assailant who's been operating right
under our nose for the past 40 years or
is he being attacked through the me2
movement by other jealous politicians
who want to kick him out of the 2020
race that is the question look I am more
than happy as a conservative
just sit back and watch the left destroy
itself I am more than happy to see a
bunch of mud slung on Joe Biden because
I don't like Joe Biden because Joe Biden
is an awful cynical politician he's
dreadful he's a demagogue he has stoked
racial division among other sorts of
division
I don't like Joe Biden but I have to be
fair and I think that this attack is BS
it's not an April Fool's joke that's
really what I think the whole affair
began because the cut I'd have never
heard of the cut before but I guess at
some online publication they just
published a piece called an awkward kiss
changed how I saw Joe Biden who was
airing this this was aired by a woman
named Lucy flores lucy flores was a
Nevada state Assemblywoman
she ran for lieutenant governor of
Nevada in 2014 this is I guess when she
met Joe Biden and had this harrowing
experience of Joe Biden putting his
hands on her shoulders and then she ran
again for Congress in 2016
she's lost in the primary there so she's
had a number of failed runs for office
she had a low-level office that she held
in Nevada and now this is her big moment
she endorsed Bernie Sanders in 2016 now
Bernie Sanders as you know is running
for president 2020 and Joe Biden wants
to run for president in 2020 and
conveniently now they are portraying Joe
Biden out to be some sexual deviant here
is what she wrote quote as I was taking
deep breaths and preparing myself to
make my case to the crowd she was about
to go onstage at a political event I
felt two hands on my shoulders I froze
why is the Vice President of the United
States touching me I felt him get closer
to me from behind he leaned further in
and inhaled my hair I was mortified I
thought to myself I didn't wash my hair
today and the Vice President of the
United States is smelling it and also
what in the actual f I'll just take a
pause from reading this for what a
stupid phrase this is that you hear
people they say what the actual f
first of all if you're a public figure
don't put swear words in print it's
unbecoming it's very undignified and
it's stupid it makes you sound stupid
don't do it but just say what the actual
f is such a trite empty it takes an
empty statement and makes it emptier
somehow I don't know how it's like
negative space is occupied by that
statement it's so awkward it's so
millennial it's just terrible
it's an awful phrase and she so she uses
this this woman who wants to be
lieutenant governor and congressman or
whatever she uses this stupid language
then then she gets to a point though why
is the vice president of the United
States smelling my hair he proceeded to
plant a big slow kiss on the back of my
head my brain couldn't process what was
happening I was embarrassed I was
shocked I was confused there is a
Spanish saying
draaga made Tierra it means earth
swallow me whole I couldn't move and I
couldn't say anything I wanted nothing
more than to get biden away from me
there are so many problems with what she
just wrote first of all she says there
is an a Spanish expression which means
earth swallow me whole but you're
writing in English you could just use
the English phrase earth swallow I
wanted the earth to swallow me whole
okay I'm nitpicking on the language
points here to make a broader point what
actually happened she was at a political
event Joe Biden comes up behind her puts
his hands on her shoulders smells her
hair which is pretty weird and then
gives her a kiss on the back of the head
not a kiss on the back of the neck not a
kiss on the cheek not a kiss on the lips
he doesn't turn her down like they just
won World War two and he plans a big wet
one in the French style no little kiss
on the back of the head does that mean
that what Joe Biden does isn't really
weird no it is really weird
does it mean that Joe Biden doesn't get
a little too much in people's comfort
zones and in their personal space yeah
he obviously does how do we know that he
does this because he's been doing it for
years and years and it's become a big
joke on TV but the question is what
actually happened here listen to her
language I
Rose I was mortified what the actual f I
was confused I was shocked the earth
should swallow me whole why because some
guy put his hands on your shoulders give
me a break here is Lucy Flores going on
CNN to talk about her harrowing - hands
on her shoulder from the vice president
do want to take a moment to acknowledge
it's not easy to do what you're doing
and I thank you for coming on and having
the courage to do so but what are you
looking for from the vice president here
Vice President Biden are you looking for
an apology are you looking for him to
change his behavior what's the endgame
here what do you want absolutely I would
yes of course I want him to change his
behavior and I want him to acknowledge
that it was wrong and I want this to be
a bigger discussion about how there is
no accountability structure within our
political space either for four
instances in which women feel that there
was inappropriate behavior or more
serious instances in allegations of
sexual assault etc we are we are not
protected in politics and and frankly on
a much larger scale we also need to have
a conversation about powerful men
feeling that they have that they have
the right to invade a woman's space
whenever they'd like so that's what this
is about this is about not what Joe
Biden did this is about the larger point
that's whenever someone says and the
larger point what they're really saying
is this particular instance don't pay
too much attention to I'm trying to make
a bigger point this is BS and don't just
take my word for it one of the women in
one of the most famous creepy Joe
massaging your shoulders moments
Stephanie Carter is calling this BS as
well you'll remember when ash Carter was
being sworn in as Secretary of Defense
his wife was there and Joe by him it was
very creepy Lee sort of massaging her
shoulders and whispering something in
her ear the meme went viral obviously we
post that all the time she just posted
on medium a long piece she said the me
to store
that wasn't me and now she begins she
says let me state upfront that I don't
know
Lucy Flores but I absolutely support her
right to speak her truth and she should
be like all women believed but her story
is not mine so here you in the one hand
she says oh this way she's a woman so
this woman has to be believed because
she's a woman women can't lie they're
not biologically capable of it
how on earth could a woman lie she would
have to say something dishonest in order
to lie women can't do that so she should
be believed she's completely right
except but her story's total BS and then
she goes on to explain White's BS
so Stephanie Carter is explaining this
moment here she says by the time then
Vice President Biden had arrived he
could sense I was uncharacteristically
nervous and quickly gave me a hug after
the swearing in as Ashe was giving
remarks he leaned in to tell me thank
you for letting him do this and kept his
hands on my shoulders as a means of
offering his support but a still shot
taken from a video misleadingly
extracted from what was a longer moment
between close friends sent out in a
snarky tweet came to be the lasting
image of the day Stephanie Carter is not
the only woman defending Joe Biden
here's Mika Brzezinski defending Joe
Biden as well on Morning Joe I don't
is it an assault what I'm not sure what
she was describing so we'll we'll listen
and try and understand where this
conversation goes from here there's a
lot of things I know about Joe Biden I'm
known him for a long time he is
extremely affectionate extremely
flirtatious in a completely safe way I
am sure that somebody can misconstrue
something he's done but as much as I can
know what's in anyone's heart I I don't
think that there's a bad intent on his
part at all and I read the account and I
was like yeah that's true fightin but
never thought for a second that he meant
anything from it except to be to be nice
to be kind
so she's defending him and now I
get why conservatives want to pounce on
the Joe Biden story because Joe Biden is
a jerk
because there's a total double standard
imagine if a Republican
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]